DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Hi, Martin.
What's up?
MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Dina.
I heard you have made one of
our company's internal web apps
serverless up on
Google Cloud platform.
Pete in the ops
team said that it's
much easier to manage that
app now that it's serverless?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh, yeah.
And it was pretty
easy to move it.
And because it's serverless
now, it requires less ops work
to keep it going.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, good.
So our company's web app
for gathering user feedback
is starting to get
more traffic now
that life is
returning to normal.
And the app went down yesterday.
And I'm starting
to feel overwhelmed
by the ops work required to
keep it running, and restarting
it, and everything.
Could you help me
make it serverless?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
I would love to.
Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
I remember hearing about
the user feedback web app.
We use it to ask our
customers questions, right?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yep, and let's see.
Here it is.
Here's a sample question.
Ask your customers what lollipop
flavor we should release next?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh, gosh.
Who's voting for kale?
Ugh.
Anyway, how does the app work?
MARTIN OMANDER: So
it's a container
that runs on a virtual machine,
which is backed by a MongoDB
database instance in the Cloud.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh, yeah.
I remember moving
that MongoDB instance
to the Cloud a
couple of years ago.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
And back in 2019, the app
got a lot more traffic
after our new product
hit the stores.
So it crashed, and no
one was around to restart
the virtual machine.
So it remained down
for a few days.
And we can't have
that happen again.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Oh, my gosh.
I remember that.
Ugh.
Also, aren't you paying for
that virtual machine 24/7?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that's the other thing.
Sometimes, we get
a lot of traffic.
And the app needs more
than one virtual machine.
But sometimes, no one is
using it for days at a time.
And we run many virtual
machines for this app--
one for production, one for
staging, a few for development.
And it's expensive to pay
for all those idle servers
or to assign someone to
turn them on and off when
they aren't needed.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Oh, I completely agree.
OK, let's start by
determining whether or not
your app is a good fit
for serverless hosting.
And I have a checklist.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that sounds great.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
OK, item number one,
is your application a web app?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, it is.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Ah, excellent.
OK, item number two, is your
application containerized?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, it sure is.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh, great.
OK, item number three, is
the container stateless?
That is, it doesn't store
user sessions and RAM
between requests or
anything like that?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
there are no user sessions,
or all the user sessions
are stored in the database.
All the data is in the database,
nothing in temporary variables
or anything like that.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Perfect.
OK, this sounds like a
good fit for Cloud Run
because it is a stateless
web app in a container.
App Engine is a great
fit for web apps,
but it doesn't use containers.
And honestly, this sounds
a little too complex
for Cloud Functions.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, OK.
Let's deploy it
on Cloud Run then.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yes,
though one moment, one note.
To be clear--
I just want to be clear--
the application doesn't have
to be in a stateless container
right now to move
it to Cloud Run,
but it would require
more steps if it weren't.
On the other hand, your use
case is very straightforward.
So let's do it.
Let's deploy your existing
container to Cloud Run.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, let's see.
I'm going to Cloud Run
here in the console.
I click here to
create a new service.
I give it a name and region.
I pick my existing container
from the Container Registry.
OK, so far, so good.
But Dina, doesn't
the container need
to be adapted somehow
for Cloud Run?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: It does.
Great question.
I've moved a few web apps from
virtual machines to Cloud Run.
And I've created a
short checklist for it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, you
really do like checklists,
don't you, Dina?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Guilty as charged.
I love them.
OK, here it is.
Variables & secrets,
connections, security,
and trigger, let's start
with the first item.
Click Advanced Settings and
then Variables & Secrets.
Click Add Variable,
and then you just
add all the
environment variables
that your container expects.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
So the virtual machine has
five environmental variables
that are used by the container.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Yeah, you're
just going to copy all
of those to Cloud Run,
but not the port variable
because Cloud Run does
that for you.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
give me a minute.
All right.
OK, so what's this
Secret sections here?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: If there
are some environment variables
that are extra sensitive
like passwords,
you can put them in Google
Cloud's Secret Manager.
That way, you get fine-grained
permissions per secret,
audit logs of who reads
and writes the secrets,
and versioning of the secrets.
It's pretty useful.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, that
does sound pretty useful.
But I don't want to update
the code in my container,
and retest the container,
and rebuild the container.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Oh,
that's OK, you don't have to.
If you've already defined
these as environment variables
in your container, you can use
the Cloud Run configuration
to expose the secrets from
Secret Manager as environment
variables.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that sounds great.
I will check that out later.
For now, let's just
keep it simple.
I will use these
normal environment
variables I have here.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Sounds good.
The next item on my
checklist is connections.
Does your container connect
to any virtual machines
in a Virtual Private
Cloud, or VPC?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, it
does connect to that MongoDB
virtual machine.
And that one only has
an internal IP address.
It's not visible on the
external public internet.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Got it.
OK, so that MongoDB
virtual machine
sits in a virtual private cloud.
When your container was also
running on a virtual machine,
it was in the VPC, and it
could connect to the MongoDB
by default. For
Cloud Run, we need
to add that VPC connection.
So you're going to
click Connections,
then create a Serverless
VPC Connector,
then Create connector.
Go ahead and give it a name.
Under Subnet, pick
Custom IP Range,
and then enter that
default that they're
showing there, 10.8.0.0.
Click Create, and
the new connector
will be available
in a minute or two.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
I did all of that.
OK, let's wait for it.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: OK, once
the connector has been created,
go back to the Cloud
Run page, and refresh
that list of VPC connectors.
Now pick the one that
you just created.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, very good.
Done.
OK, so that was number two
on your four-item checklist.
What's the next one?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Ah,
the next one is security.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
well as you know,
Dina, security is
important to our company.
How should I set
up strong security?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
You should always
use the principle
of least privilege.
This container should only have
the minimum privileges needed
to do its job and no more.
You could run this container
as the default compute engine
service account, but that
account has more permissions
than your container needs.
So go to the Security tab,
and click Create New Service
Account.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, I
see that the system here
suggested a name for
this new service account.
It looks like it's based on the
name of the Cloud Run service.
That's nice.
That will make it easy
to keep track of things.
I'm clicking Create here.
Oh, should I grant it any
additional permissions here?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Does your container
access any other
Google Cloud products?
MARTIN OMANDER: No, it only
accesses that MongoDB instance.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
OK, then there's
no need to grant
additional permissions.
And that's good.
This is a good thing.
If a coworker of
ours accidentally
adds code to the
container that tries
to access any other resource
in this project, it will fail.
And that is safer for everybody.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that does feel good.
OK, so far, so good.
What's the fourth item
on your checklist?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
It's trigger.
So we need to configure how
the service is triggered.
So go ahead and
click that section,
and we'll walk through it.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, done.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
First, you need
to set which networks
can access the service.
If it's a public web app, you
want to pick Allow All Traffic.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, so
I'm leaving that as it is.
What are the two other
radio buttons for, Dina?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: The second
radio button, Allow Internal
Traffic and Traffic From
Cloud Load Balancing,
is for apps that
get their traffic
from another internal
application or via a load
balancer.
You need to put a load balancer
in front of your service
to use Cloud Armor
for protection
or Identity-Aware Proxy
for authentication.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it,
and the third radio button?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Oh, that one's
useful if your service is an
internal microservice that
should only be reachable by
other services in your project.
If you pick that
option, your service
will not be visible to
the public internet.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, got it.
Let's see.
The next section here
says Authentication.
What should I pick there?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
Well, this app is public,
so you should stick to
the first radio button.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
OK, I'll do that.
But what would happen if I
picked the second radio button?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Well,
then only service accounts
which have the Cloud
Run Invoker permission
would be able to
trigger your service.
And the public wouldn't
be able to use it at all.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, got it.
Is that it?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Yes.
Click the Create button.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ooh, all right.
Clicking it now.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
OK, let's wait
for the deployment to finish.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
It looks like the
deployment is done.
That was quick.
And what now?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Cloud
Run has given your new service
a URL.
Do you see it there
in the Cloud Console?
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, there it is.
I'm clicking it.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
And there it
is, your existing container
running serverlessly
in Cloud Run.
As a side note, if you wanted a
different URL for your service,
you could set that up by
clicking Custom Domain.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nice, and
the application is working.
So to recap, what
was your checklist
for moving an existing container
serverlessly to Cloud Run?
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
OK, first, check
what environment variables
your container is using,
and enter them in the
Cloud Run user interface.
You can also set
them from the command
line with the gcloud command.
For sensitive data,
consider putting them
in Secret Manager for added
security and auditing.
And you can still
access these values
as environment variables.
So you won't have to edit the
code inside your container.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: Then if
your container accesses servers
within a virtual private cloud,
like a database, for instance,
set up a serverless VPC
connector to the VPC
where your server lives.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
After that is security.
Create a new
service account that
has the minimum
privileges needed to let
the container do its job.
Configure Cloud Run to use
that new service account.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, yeah,
I remember doing that.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN:
And finally, we
need to configure how
the service is triggered.
If it's a public web app,
pick Allow All Traffic.
If your app gets traffic from
the Google Cloud load balancer,
you'd pick that option.
And if your service is an
internal-only service that
should not be reachable
from the public internet,
pick the option for that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
This checklist will
make it a lot easier
to move other
containers to Cloud Run
so I don't have to maintain
those pesky servers.
DINA GRAVES PORTMAN: And you
get autoscaling with Cloud Run.
So if the thousands of customers
want to vote on our next candy
flavor, the container
will automatically
be deployed to more instances.
And bonus, you're not paying
for it when it's not in use.
MARTIN OMANDER: That sounds like
the best kind of flavor to me.
Thank you, everyone,
for watching.
If you have questions for me
or Dina about moving containers
to Cloud Run, please let
us know in the comments.
Also, if you have suggestions
for future videos,
please enter them below.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]